[Music]  very handsome world leader who I shall  not name invites me to dinner at the  Baldwin where he's staying  all right so we get there and he tells  me he has this very important question  he has to ask me and I'm thinking okay  well he's gonna invite me up to his room  so I'm considering my answer when he  turns her and asked me if I was baptized  what yeah no yes yeah I just burst out  laughing and said no but apparently yeah  yeah only sleeps with good Catholics  that's insane  yeah actually I kind of kind of  attracted that he believed in something  so there's so with that what about you  car are you seeing anyone I'm actually  still getting over a relationship he  moved away  yeah what about Ruby's father's he's  still in the picture  nope it's just me and Ruby Wow raising a  daughter by yourself that's that's  incredible  yeah I mean how do you do that supergirl  all-new episode Monday at 8:00 7:00  central on the CW  [Music]  you